Traduttore: Alice Esercitato
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Io sono una ricercatrice
nel campo della scienza dei materiali.
Si tratta di un settore
della ricerca scientifica
che vede coinvolte
diverse figure professionali,
tra cui chimici, fisici e ingegneri.
In generale, spetta ai chimici
il ruolo di creare nuovi materiali
a partire dalla loro formulazione.
Io sono un ingegnere
e mi occupo di cambiarne
forme e composizione
al fine di conferire loro
particolari proprietà.
I materiali con cui lavoro
sono noti sotto il nome di polimeri,
ovvero macromolecole,
cioè costituite da un gran numero
di unità ripetenti, uguali o diverse,
legate tra di loro per formare una catena.
Possono essere di origine sintetica,
semisintetica o anche naturale.
Ci sono diverse tecnologie
che possono tornare utili
per cambiare la forma dei polimeri;
e la scienza va nella direzione
in cui ognuno possa dar sfogo
alla propria immaginazione
in un modo molto semplice
ed anche piuttosto intuitivo:
sto pensando per esempio
alle stampanti 3D,
per cui un operatore
può essere un privato cittadino
o anche, per esempio,
una équipe di medici chirurghi.
Eppure, nell'immaginario collettivo,
al termine polimeri, o plastica,
siamo soliti associare
la bottiglia dell'acqua minerale,
eppure si è costituita da una [sola]
delle tantissime specie di polimeri
che vengono oggi utilizzati.
E ve ne sono alcuni che possono assumere
delle forme talmente confortevoli
da poter essere indossati.
Queste sono delle maglie di uso comune,
e sempre più di frequente
leggiamo sulle etichette
che c'è la presenza di materiali
come il poliestere, il nylon, l'acrilico.
In effetti,
i polimeri sono entrati
nell'industria tessile
alla fine dell'800, primi anni del '900,
perché avevano delle
caratteristiche peculiari
che li rendevano superiori
rispetto alle fibre naturali;
parlo ad esempio della flessibilità,
dove si tratta di flessibilità
non solo di forma,
ma anche degli utilizzi
che se ne possono fare,
oppure una maggiore durabilità nel tempo,
o maggiore elasticità.
Avrete sicuramente sentito parlare,
e avrete sicuramente utilizzato
dei tessuti in microfibra.
La microfibra è un filato
due volte più leggero della seta
e tre volte più leggero del cotone.
Viene realizzato attraverso
un processo di filatura
che permette di modificarne
forma e dimensioni
cambiando le dimensioni
dell'orifizio da cui fuoriesce.
Caratteristiche principali
di un tessuto in microfibra
sono l'estrema leggerezza
e sofficità al tatto;
ma la cosa molto interessante,
e che le rende così estremamente versatili
è che, con lo stesso materiale,
è possibile realizzare
dei tessuti traspiranti
o anche dei tessuti antivento.
Ebbene, le dimensioni di una microfibra
sono di circa 10 micrometri,
ovvero confrontabili con le dimensioni
del capello di un uomo.
È possibile realizzare delle fibre
centinaia di volte più piccole?
Quest'immagine ad alta risoluzione,
realizzata presso i nostri laboratori,
mostra il capello di un uomo, al centro,
avvolto da un'intricata matassa di fili.
Si tratta di nanofibre di polimero
centinaia di volte più sottili
rispetto al capello
e quindi centinaia di volte più sottili
rispetto alle microfibre.
E i nostri studi hanno dimostrato
che cambiando forma e dimensioni
di questa matassa di fibre
è possibile conferire al tessuto
delle particolari proprietà.
E questi tessuti sono interessanti
in svariati settori applicativi,
per esempio nella filtrazione.
La superficie specifica
di questi tessuti aumenta così tanto
che è possibile, per esempio,
filtrare gli oggetti più piccoli,
il particolato più piccolo;
o ancora, è possibile utilizzare
dei polimeri biocompatibili:
significa che possonono interagire
con i sistemi viventi,
senza alterarne le funzioni vitali,
per realizzare degli "scaffolds".
È un termine inglese
che significa impalcatura.
Gli scaffolds sono molto utilizzati
in ingegneria tissutale e rigenerativa
e sono dei supporti che vengono offerti
al tessuto da rigenerare.
Ancora, è possibile utilizzare
dei polimeri biocompatibili,
e anche piezoelettrici,
per trasformare energia meccanica
in energia elettrica.
Ed è questo quello di cui parleremo oggi.
Vediamo innanzitutto come funziona
un materiale piezoelettrico.
Nello schema che state vedendo
è rappresentato dal rettangolo centrale,
che è connesso,
tramite due cavi elettrici,
all'estremità di uno strumento
chiamato voltmetro,
che è uno strumento in grado di misurare
una differenza di potenziale.
Immaginiamo di applicare
una pressione a questo materiale.
Esso, di conseguenza, si deformerà.
Ogni volta che il materiale si deforma,
si generano, sulla sua superficie,
delle cariche elettriche di segno opposto
che danno origine
ad una differenza di potenziale
che andremo a leggere
sul nostro strumento, il voltmetro.
Vediamo una piccola simulazione.
All'aumentare della pressione
che applichiamo,
aumenterà di conseguenza
la deformazione indotta nel materiale,
ed aumenterà il valore di voltaggio
che andremo a leggere.
Nella vita comune,
il principio della piezoelettricità
è molto utilizzato:
pensiamo, per esempio, all'accendino.
Ogni volta che noi premiamo,
il materiale piezoelettrico
che si trova al suo interno si deforma,
e deformandosi dà origine
ad un arco elettrico
all'interno del box che contiene il gas.
E quindi, si genera la fiamma.
Ci sono molti materiali piezoelettrici
che sono di origine naturale:
il quarzo, per esempio.
È la piezoelettricità
il principio di funzionamento
alla base degli orologi al quarzo.
Altri materiali naturali sono il topazio,
o anche lo zucchero di canna,
e si possono fare tanti altri esempi
di oggetti che contengono
materiali piezoelettrici
e che ne sfruttano il funzionamento:
per esempio i sensori dell'airbag,
o anche la chitarra acustica.
Ma cos'hanno in comune questi materiali
che ho adesso menzionato:
l'accendino, la chitarra, l'airbag?
Si tratta di oggetti
dotati di una propria forma,
anche rigidi, e in molti casi fragili.
Fragili così come sono fragili
i materiali piezoelettrici
che ne abilitano la funzione.
Infatti, nella maggior parte dei casi,
i materiali piezoelettrici utilizzati
sono di origine ceramica.
E hanno un altro grave difetto,
e cioè che avendo forma propria
ed essendo così fragili,
non sono "conformabili",
cioè non sono in grado di assumere
la forma dell'oggetto
sul quale vengono posizionati.
Questo è un materiale piezoelettrico
in forma di tessuto.
Esso, così come appare, è estremamente
morbido, leggero, flessibile,
può essere piegato a volte
senza danneggiarsi
e in più ha anche
una buona resistenza meccanica.
È stato realizzato
attraverso un processo di filatura
molto simile a quello utilizzato
per realizzare le microfibre.
Solo che, in questo caso,
il processo è coadiuvato
dalla presenza di un campo elettrico.
Osservato ad un microscopio
ad elevato ingrandimento,
questo è il modo in cui
questo tessuto appare,
cioè un intreccio di fili
centinaia di volte più piccoli
rispetto alle microfibre.
Quindi, questo tessuto:
ha tutte le proprietà e i vantaggi
dei materiali polimerici;
è biocompatibile; è piezoelettrico;
e non basta, è anche
estremamente sensibile al tatto.
Questo è un modello molto comune e diffuso
di smartphone touchscreen.
Ogni volta che desideriamo
eseguire un'operazione,
premiamo leggermente
sulla superficie del display.
In questo modo, riusciamo ad abilitare
la funzione desiderata.
La pressione che noi applichiamo
è pari a circa 2000 pascal.
Proviamo adesso a pensare
a quale possa essere la pressione
che una farfalla esercita su un fiore
quando si posa su di esso.
Questa è la vanessa del cardo,
splendido esemplare di insetto migratore
che ogni anno migra
dalle coste del Sudafrica
fino al Mediterraneo
e poi su fino alla Gran Bretagna,
per poi tornare indietro
e concludere il suo ciclo.
Le farfalle hanno sei zampe,
e gli esemplari più piccoli
pesano dieci milligrammi,
quindi sono in grado di esercitare
una pressione pari a due pascal,
cioè mille volte inferiore
rispetto alla pressione
che noi esercitiamo
sullo schermo del nostro telefonino.
E quel tessuto che vi ho mostrato
è in grado di generare energia
a partire da una pressione
dieci volte inferiore
a quella esercitata dalla farfalla
che si posa su di un fiore,
cioè 10.000 volte inferiore
rispetto al nostro tocco, gentile,
quando utilizziamo lo smartphone.
Questo significa che ogni volta
che un piccolo insetto,
o anche una foglia,
o anche una debole folata di vento,
perturba il tessuto,
esso è potenzialmente in grado
di generare energia elettrica.
Chiaramente, le applicazioni
sono tantissime:
proviamo a vederne qualcuna.
Sarà possibile generare energia
a partire da qualsiasi forma di movimento,
quindi una camminata, una passeggiata,
o anche le onde del mare, onde meccaniche;
o anche suoni, rumori, vibrazioni,
perché è estremamente sensibile
anche alle onde acustiche,
oppure le folate di vento.
Questi sono movimenti
ai quali generalmente sono associate
delle forze piuttosto consistenti,
per cui verrebbe da pensare:
"Vabbè, magari è anche possibile
utilizzare un materiale piezoelettrico
un po' più fragile:
purché ben impacchettato,
funzionerà nello stesso modo".
È vero:
però ci sono tantissime applicazioni
della vita quotidiana
nelle quali, se ci pensassimo,
semplicemente sostituendo
il tessuto in microfibra
con un tessuto piezoelettrico,
potremmo generare energia elettrica
a partire da energia meccanica
che quotidianamente
viene spesa e inutilizzata.
Potremmo foderare, per esempio,
tende e tendaggi, ombrelloni,
o anche giacche antivento per la pioggia,
perché in ognuno di questi casi
o il vento, o la pioggia
esercitano una forza sul tessuto.
E possiamo raccogliere
l'energia che il tessuto genera.
Qui sono rappresentate
tantissime altre applicazioni
a cui possiamo pensare;
pensiamo, per esempio, al corpo umano,
l'apparato cardiocircolatorio:
60-80 battiti al minuto.
Significa 60-80 distensioni e contrazioni
in cui il tessuto potrebbe caricarsi
per produrre uno-due volt di tensione
che sarebbero sufficienti
ad alimentare un pacemaker,
quindi il cuore sarebbe in grado
di autoalimentare il proprio pacemaker:
oppure pensiamo al mondo dello sport,
dove l'interazione
tra il tessuto indossato
e il corpo che lo indossa
potrebbe permettere di generare energia
o anche di interagire a livello locale.
E questo lo può fare in due modi:
un modo potrebbe essere
che il tessuto memorizza informazioni
del muscolo sul quale è posizionato,
ne segue il movimento,
e queste informazioni
possano essere d'aiuto
per tutti coloro che studiano
il logorio muscolare,
oppure lo studio della prestazione;
un'altra possibilità potrebbe essere
che ogni volta che esercitiamo un muscolo,
facciamo attività fisica,
o che comunque compiamo degli sforzi,
il tessuto interagisce col sistema
e genera alcuni millivolt,
o anche volt di tensione,
che poi può rilasciare al sistema vivente
sotto forma di picchi di energia,
e in questo modo è possibile ottenere
degli scopi riabilitivi.
Ora, le applicazioni potrebbero
essere tantissime,
alcune di queste
sono in fase di sperimentazione
presso l'Istituto di Nanoscienze a Lecce.
Il tempo stringe,
e io mi avvio alla conclusione;
però, prima di farlo,
vorrei ringraziare
lo European Research Council
che ci ha permesso di iniziare
e proseguire questo meraviglioso viaggio,
E soprattutto, grazie a voi
per l'attenzione.
(Applausi)